a rescue team throws a lifeline to abdul
majid's family his daughter-in-law is
eight months pregnant and needs urgent
medical care they had been stranded for
days when they spotted this rescue boat
and called for help
we faced a lot of difficulty for four
days it was tough to get food and
drinking water we eventually got some
relief the water level was about one and
a half meters high
heavy rains have caused floods in parts
of assam state in india's northeast
impacting 700 000 people
hojai district in central assam is one
of the worst affected areas
thousands of homes have been damaged
since flooding began last week
receding water levels are making it more
difficult to evacuate people
rescue boats like this one continue to
cross over submerged paddy fields the
water in some parts is estimated to be
at least 15 feet deep the retrieving
bodies carrying relief material and
rescuing stranded villagers who've been
stuck without food and other necessities
for days
dozens of families are staying in this
relief camp some have been staying for a
week they say they need more help from
the government
we worry about our future we don't know
what we will do we don't think there's
any hope for us we have left our cattle
and we don't have enough to eat we have
been here for a while and we are still
waiting for help
assam often sees floods during the
monsoon season this year the rains have
come early and are more intense hojai
hasn't seen major flooding in 18 years
our main challenge was the communication
how we reached to the people so he
called upon army to provide boats and
all helped us a lot so
so far as water was
water had the minimum level that boats
could play so now to send after
evacuation now our challenge is to reach
out to people who are still staying in
remote areas
rescue teams say despite high water
levels many villagers are unwilling to
leave those who have are hoping to
return soon so they can start rebuilding
their lives pav nimittal al-jazeera
hojai district in northeast india